this is day nine of cooking Comfort
foods from every country today my friend
Holly is showing me how to make
Taiwanese minced pork noodles wow this
is so l so you want to soak the shitake
mushrooms in hot water until they're
nice and plump give it a rough chop
going to add some cooking oil and then
cook the garlic and onions until the
onions are translucent so how often do
you make this dish literally once a week
oh wow sugar just to caramelize the
onion five spice the smell and then we
can add in the Starnes actually how long
does lasts you guys it'll last us maybe
2 days it goes fast oh yeah that's Shing
wine light and dark soy sauce ooh that
looks so good that water up till it
fills the top I'll add in the eggs
you're getting tucked in cover the lid
and let it cook for 30 to 45 minutes
this smells amazing oh yeah get in there
these are tanes wheat noodles add in the
sauce the meat sauce wo it tastes like
it has like a bazilian ingredients in
here but it doesn't and it's so simple